[Musique]
c'est une surprise pour moi c'est ce qu
on a deux surprises ça de surplus on
attend tron fait de l'animateur de la
décennie non ce progrès comparé à mener
non mais un vampire il est là alors et
on a en fait quelle surprise pour moi le
trophée et bah tu fais là il paraît que
c'est une surprise pour moi alors ça
c'est le trophée
non c'est magnifique on merci
ça remonte à l'après guerre comme
thébaux r d'ailleurs le toit de ce côté
non mais fermée si incroyablement
développerait mais je m'en fous mais
c'est où ce que tu as fait mouche bougez
bougez était tout de suite du regain oui
mais c'est vrai mais comment t'as fait
ça modifie ses deux talents et c'est le
talent mais je vous dis c'est énorme si
tu es non mais tu sais que c'est le plus
beau trophée je te jure que jamais reçue
m'a dit c'est l'animateur de l'animateur
de la décennie 2010
du coup c'est l'état qui devait devenir
ma une surprise pour toi demain et tout
çà et là une grande histoire d'amour est
magnifique lundi foot cqt temps à mon
métier qu'il est magnifique mais quand
je te dis magnifique c'est magnifique et
ça pèse une tonne
ça me suis à dire que je te le répète on
voit toujours ma gueule c'est notre
problème c'est pas cool merci merci mon
cher alors correcte et une autre
surprise en afrique tout n'est pas fait
que des sûr il faut que je t'emmène
quelques parce que c'est là un nazi
alors ça c'est une reprise de la
production
c'est une surprise avec chéri de toyal
non d'accord mais c'est de la production
mais quand donc on va se parler m
et 25 ans ça se fête et essayent tout et
qui fait peur
toi tu les connais pas le shérif
tendance à empêcher les qui tu es merci
d'être là les amours alors c'est ça
alors c'est que des jeunes de tous voilà
qui nous occupe le regarde depuis des
années c'est facile et chérie et ses
magnifiques cette petite scène et tout
j'adore
alors ils vont préparer le téléthon
prépare une petite surprise une telle
chanson pour sa provoc je vais lancer
une chorale mois en général c'est là on
va faire une chorale vous êtes frère
s'il est à licha je vous laisse avec
avec le m merci bon anniversaire série
chérie merci inverse ya une chanson
[Musique]
il ya des matches à l'heure
chaque fois c'est la même
nous on ne suit depuis on en est très
fier
la mairie
à toi
oh
ce que c'est
chaud
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la pause